hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and the kipster
make sure you subscribe to the youtube
page that way you get the videos
as they come out welcome to another
exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage the show where
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and find out if they grow up classy or
if they're a big old piece of trash
i'm your host h foley coming at you on a
beautiful day here at aunt tooty studio
we're down here in the basement
she's upstairs had a little oral surgery
yesterday
real stingy with the vikes i'll tell you
that but she's got the joint set up nice
for thanksgiving
the smell down here is unbelievable it
smells like pine cones oh my god okay
[Laughter]
i'm really selling it he's really taking
some liberties on these intros
the past couple of weeks you don't think
i got a spin-off cooking that i'm
pitching hey
shakespeare wrapping up no one's tuning
in for these
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he's my pal he keeps me in
line he's my
into my yang i don't know what i would
[ __ ] do without him
gang the next time you reach you for a
best pal you know the drill make it a
kippy
give it up for kevin james ryan hey
what's up everybody thanks so much for
tuning in as always we
really appreciate it please make sure
you rate review subscribe on itunes
those numbers we were top 200 today no
big deal you know what i mean
send that to the boss up in corporate
we're already out
in and out like that we felt we fell
shook some hands kissed some babies and
we got the [ __ ] at it all of you show it
off
[ __ ] steve jobs you know go [ __ ]
yourself uh also youtube uh you can
subscribe there full video in [ __ ] hd
baby that's what we're talking
uh those numbers are through the roof as
well we really appreciate that
and then obviously the things that pay
the bills what are we talking here you
know what i'm talking about patreon.com
are you garbage the goods go sign up you
got it we need it
let's go um you get bonus episodes bonus
videos i'm doing coffee with kippy
you're doing some food videos doing some
food videos the bonuses are great it's
cooking good times
it's real content we're gonna be doing
live stream with you guys at the end of
the month
uh yeah it's a good time and also i mean
there's a lot of [ __ ] business we
gotta get out of uh
shirts too go to podcastmerch.com you
can get yourself garbagio shirts clean
living shirts [ __ ] making the kippy
shirts the milkman shirts go
get them help us pay the rent in this
[ __ ] place it's due in a week
just in time and kippy is out of
operating capital
mom if you hear this i need money so act
now
let's take a minute let's tip our caps
to our producer extraordinaire he's the
magic man new nickname t-bone floating
around the office and he doesn't like it
that's how you know it's going to stay
let's see
toby mcmullen everybody
all right but let's get to the business
here to four we could not
be more excited to have our incredibly
special guest here with us today
a very requested guest you wanted her we
got her she's here she's a big guest
we're excited to have her here she's a
very successful stand-up comedian actor
and
entrepreneur all right as an actor she's
appeared in data management
she has a podcast out called thirst
strap and she is the co-founder
of the magazine classy trashy
co-founder name on the manifest
[ __ ] big time you keep saying that i
don't know if that's the right word i
don't know it's from social network one
of them had the name on the man of test
the other one got screwed gang do me a
favor give me a nice big round of
applause
for natalie cuomo everybody hey thanks
for having me
thanks for coming coming in very
requested
and uh very i mean you're living in the
world of trash that's
it's kind of your brand i am i am living
in the world of trash i love it but it's
very sleek i've seen the magazines
it's it's listen her trash and your
trash are a little different
she's cool hip trash you're [ __ ] out
by the dumpster
trash is leather jackets and motorcycles
mines haven't showered in a couple of
days and eating some questionable food
out of the refrigerator
yeah you know what i did change my
tampon
in the sci-fi aisle of barnes noble
yesterday holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] holy [ __ ] why were you in
a barnes and noble let's start you
needed to change yourself
in the bathroom they're close to the
public yeah that's true that's tough
that's why you see so
you see so many people pissing and
[ __ ] everywhere because all the
bathrooms
yeah it's more unsanitary to do this you
know what i don't get about
the homeless poop in new york city why
are we just gonna breeze over she
changed her tampons
sci-fi section we're gonna move back to
it why do they poop on the wall why why
is it because it
it blocks that way if you're i've
thought about this a lot because like
all right you think you would squat
go go they will they bend down because
nobody can see behind you then you only
have 180 degree
of people that can see you [ __ ] you
don't want to have your
defense yeah exactly all right um
what'd you do with the other tampon
since you brought it up goddamn dewey
decimal system
i
man did you wrap it up or anything you
bare hand it oh my god you can't grab a
napkin on your way in it was urgent
paperback something
paperback i was going through my pants i
needed a
holy [ __ ] it's hard being a woman that's
tough i
that's i mean that's not that's that's
not right it ain't classy
the [ __ ] queen of england ain't doing
that
but at the same time you're end up in a
bad situation i get it
yeah wow i i think it's resourceful more
than anything of course
yeah yeah yeah i mean did they say sorry
the bathrooms are closed to the public
it was a situation where i was like my
pants are gonna have a stain in t minus
30 seconds
so you walked in you said hey excuse me
it's okay if i use the bathroom no i
looked around
i i saw the sign on the bathroom door
that said nope
and i got to thinking yeah was there a
reason you picked sci-fi were you like
this will be
you know are you more of like a
non-fiction kind of gal a bunch of nerds
in here
show these nerds what a [ __ ] looks like
i've always hated sci-fi
yeah damn funny all right so well let me
ask you this now
do you not not in the cool edgy way the
mag
did you buy anything
[Laughter]
do you think you're garbage um
no you don't oh interesting i was
thinking about it today i was listening
to some podcast some of your podcasts
this morning
walking my dog and i was like i'm not
garbage okay well we'll get to the
bottom
that might be i like it i like a
challenge there's very few people that
came in
and said i'm not garbage and ended up
not being garbage
that's valid i think there's only two
really
we're gonna find out huh and we're gonna
start now because now i got a [ __ ]
chip on my shoulder
let's see what's happening let's start
with number one
where'd you grow up give us the origin
story of natalie cuomo okay
i grew up in bayside queens okay high
school moved to astoria
okay public high school private high
school public
public apartment building two family
home one family home
a little apartment building a little
apartment building yeah did your family
own the building
no you rented the apartment yes brothers
and sisters
no i was like oh man she's under [ __ ]
oath right now
she's always [ __ ] she's playing a lot
of defense
yeah yeah i like it she's like listen
here fatso i ain't giving you the
[ __ ]
i ain't giving you the rope to hang me
keep it moving
plugs the magazine walks out see a dorks
smacks a sticker on your head
no brothers and sisters no i have three
step brothers and this might be
a dumb question that brother's on what
side
your parents have divorced when um they
separated
when i was in fifth grade got divorced
when i was senior in high school
oh that's a long separation well here we
go were they back and forth a little bit
or just like completely separated just
never filed the papers they my mom slept
on the couch the whole time okay here we
go that's
it here we go i like how that so what
was that three minutes
your mom and dad have separated for a
decade and she sleeps on the couch
that's
[ __ ] right there that's sagalow family
[ __ ] pedigree right there my
wow all right now let's back it up a
little bit
okay so you're an only child you have
your mom and your dad you're living out
in bayside
you said in high school you moved to
an apartment in astoria with my mom i
did a half half and half
how was what was it weekly or weekends
or what you did every other week every
other week you do a week with your mom
and then go a week with your dad you're
gonna go to bayside
what'd you do high school i took the q28
and the seven training
i was in the back of the yellow bus with
a capri sun lady you're garbage
there's no [ __ ] school buses it's
crazy too i always say kids in the city
they grow up when they're sick
oh i remember crying my eyes out when
the yellow bus dropped me off in like
sixth grade and my mom was there to pick
me up just like
you guys are taking the [ __ ] subway
at like four years old there's something
bad
doing showtime dancing and [ __ ] like
that yeah yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
it does it does grow you up quick for
sure
so your dad stayed in bayside is this
when they got separated in fifth grade
okay so we're in fifth grade right now
mm-hmm your mom moves to astoria
no no she moved to astoria in the middle
of high school so you guys stayed in the
same apartment
after they were separated and why did
your mom sleep on the couch you figured
the old man would be out there where's
chivalry's dead i guess once you're
separated you're like yo
if you ain't paying her in hit the pull
out yeah exactly
so it was the three of you yep and how
did that all go explain that talk about
that a little bit did they keep it like
yeah civil friendly did you have dinner
what happened to them like a springsteen
song in there what was the deal
um well i became a comedian so there you
go you know
it was uh it wasn't moonlightening
yeah it wasn't like my two dads or
anything yeah it wasn't awesome
but it was it was just fine did they go
back and they argue a little bit
yeah i mean here's the thing if you i
think when you give up on a relationship
you stop arguing because you're like
because there's no real passion it's
true
you're like i don't give a [ __ ] and they
both live their separate lives
would they eat dinner together or no um
sometimes
how was that for you that's weird
because my parents divorced and then
even when they would see each other like
drop-offs and [ __ ] i'd be like yo don't
make eye contact this is awkward
look away it was weird you're going back
and forth like you're in the mob
whispered in each other's ears yeah yeah
dad said he'd have to check next week
now let me tell you dad didn't have to
check next week
well they still call they're obviously
still cool to you like you still did
things that your dad you still do things
with your mind yeah
yeah they're they're cool with each
other now they're oh yeah now
they all get cool yeah after you're all
[ __ ] up and damaged
i know everybody's cool now oh they're
working it out yeah [ __ ] you
all right i'm in my [ __ ] room writing
songs in [ __ ] sixth grade
what about holidays would they pull
together for that did you have extended
family around
you so yeah they pretended to be
together for a little
bit for the extended family nice so
i think that's why i love holidays why
because it's a normal
glimpse of normality yeah because
everybody was faking being happy
i love festive [ __ ] i love it that's
funny i love it
covering up the wounds
uh for did they do it for a certain side
of the family was like they were like
was the dad's side like hey listen we
got to keep it together
for my mom or something or was it just
kind of understood that yeah who was the
family where were you we did
thanksgiving with the dad
i mean most of the holidays with my
dad's side okay they're from queens
they're yeah they're from they're both
sides are from queens both sides are
from queens
interesting but those families get along
together yeah they're
fine okay and obviously your mom and dad
grew up together out there in bayside
no my mom grew up in jackson heights my
dad grew up in bellerose
that's a real queen story though yeah
[ __ ] saturday night's evening
yeah yeah it probably meant something i
thought she was gonna like no my mom
grew up in florida she grew up like you
know [ __ ] seven minutes away
yeah so you're like you're like new york
you're like queens you're grew and swore
i am
son of sam the whole nine yards the son
of dad yeah
all right very interesting so they kept
it together so you guys lived
why did he move with you he did it oh he
did the mama
uh yeah so they did the sleeping on the
couch thing you gotta
you gotta give him a couple of minutes
to catch up this is like trash dynasty
it is i might be trash i like how she's
like
together what did your dad do growing up
uh he was an english teacher at queen's
college
that's respectable and mom uh landscape
architect
ah architect's pretty good arkansas
you're gonna say landscaper i was like
they breed them rough in queens
landscape architecture
that's white collar [ __ ] though that's
very and i know i did a little research
on you
i know you're an educated person as well
she went to bard college very classy
private college in the hudson valley
liberal arts college that's a little bit
of kids are you smart do you think
um what'd you get on your sats this is a
big question so yeah yeah
i i know that and i can't wait to tell
you i didn't even take that say tease
what you're that smart no i
i'm not stupid i guess at a liberal arts
college you probably didn't need to
yeah i like it listen you could take
them if you want but uh it ain't gonna
be good
yeah they're like we care more about
your essays
but i thought you what's the act it's
like the alternative
is that a that's that's the one that's
out of like 22 points or whatever
22
how many questions are there i don't
know that's like a lot
yeah yeah oh i'd be pissed on toby's got
something
a good student in school you went to a
lib did you go you went to a performing
arts high school though
right you went to a straight regular
high school i went to a height my high
school was bard high school early
college queens
it was the first year it was a floor in
a school in elmhurst and then the next
three years it was
a floor in uh school in long island city
talking about not being able to pay the
rent on the lease
[Laughter]
what kind of schools switches year to
year
talk about keeping a low profile who
rents out a floor in another school what
kind of [ __ ] is that
yeah it was uh it was trashy for sure
jeez what was that like anybody could go
there or was that like
you got relegated there for some reason
i thought it was performing arts or
something like that no it wasn't
performing arts you took a uh
you took it you took like a test for
that school but one of the questions was
on the test what's the square root of
uh 144 or something yeah it was very
easy very easy i would have never got
that i was thinking too
screw to nine is three right there you
go there you go look at me
where's that [ __ ] ac mr 890 over here
watch out
so you went to a good school and you
went away to college
yeah so once your senior year was over
with your parents that was all kind of
yeah put behind you yeah yeah yeah okay
yep i graduated college at 20. that's
quick
yeah that's really quick yeah many did
you drink did you do it i did three
yeah why did you take summer classes no
because that was awesome
[Laughter]
night school did you go to night school
no i just feel like i don't get enough
credit for being smart in my life so
that's great you didn't take the sats
what are you supposed to go on yeah some
of you got a 27
on some [ __ ] tests i think you could
have been doing [ __ ] knock knock
jokes i don't know
it could have been card tricks for all
and it's true it's true that's pretty
good three years that's i mean that's a
[ __ ] mover and shaker did you just
stack three years
of credits well my high school was like
oh early
yeah supposed to be like early college
yeah this all sounds like a setup did
you have to pay to go to this high
school
no it was like for like a charter school
it's supposed to be like diverse
the high school okay and had you paid to
go to college though right
yeah i did pay to go to college all
right your papa's flipping that pill
your mom and your dad
my grandma oh all right here we go so is
there a little bit of cash in the family
no grandma just had a little nest egg
yeah she doesn't know she was paying i
kept going into her sock short every
semester
grabbing a couple of [ __ ] stacks out
obviously no relation to the governor
no okay no why do you say obviously um
i don't know from the living on the
couch thing and
a couple other tidbits information i've
picked up in the last 10 minutes
you weren't at the [ __ ] governor's
mansion having lemonades and mint juleps
no um i just thought it would be too
easy you know what i mean and you would
have maybe mentioned that right off the
bat
right yeah but i figured queens cuomo
yeah you said you were from tennessee is
he from queensland
he's from new york yeah he's like he's
he's like upstate he's not a city guy
okay he grew up in like syracuse or
something that's all
phone at all that's all phone where this
is a non-political show
all right unless my mom calls in again
yikes passes himself off as a real
[ __ ] new york
tough guy for a kid from [ __ ]
rochester
all right so that's the [ __ ] story
i'm i don't i mean
i'm just torn going into this a little
bit i mean the family situation
obviously that's a little dicey but that
happens and that doesn't determine
no whether you're trash or not so let's
get into some of you garbage here all
right okay i see we're gonna have to do
this the traditional way you're still
holding on saying you're not garbage
where are we at
i'm starting to bend a little bit okay
i'm garbage but
yeah is there anything in the origin
story you're not telling us that would
maybe shield it you're playing anything
close to the chest yeah what are you
doing
i don't know that you know you're
[ __ ] something [ __ ] up yeah
something [ __ ] up or not like not like
you know my aunt got her arm ripped off
or anything i think the most garbage
thing about me
is that i every time i think i'm gonna
marry someone i get their name tattooed
and i've had to cover up two people's
names
yes that's something crazy
uh objection your honor she was
withholding evidence at the discovery
period
let's go here we go where are the
tattoos
okay so one is like uh oh yeah you're
all tatted up too it's a little
different
she's got a lot of tattoos that is a
little different but that's very cool
these
arm and wrestling sheep arm and rib oh a
rib pad of a guy's name
what's his name if you don't or do you
nominate daniel and what was the second
guy's name
john so you got you were engaged to both
of these people i wasn't engaged i just
liked them a lot
oh my god wait a minute but you were in
a relationship with them yeah but we
were like oh we're going to get
married i love you love love love sure
that happens okay
no it doesn't what are you talking about
a little bit when you're young
when you're younger sure all right not a
meathead like you
all right unromantic okay what are you
talking about
do you get romantic yeah get snuggly
while you turn these lights off i'll
show you huh
well hold on what was if you don't mind
how old are you now can i ask you how
old are you i
am 25. holy [ __ ] you're young you're
young
all right because i was going to say
when was the last person you did that to
in what year
like who was the last one john or danny
so i'm currently engaged someone named
jake i have his name
five times
yikes jake you ain't going anywhere
buddy takes a lot of tattoo removal
money
pack a bag hit the
[Laughter]
you don't have it like jake jake taking
a roll like a joker or something like
that do you
no i'm okay where are the five of jake
oh yeah you're trash
i'm sorry i'm sorry you aren't cherry
who got it first you were hammer did you
go together hmm
does he know about the other two people
sorry does he know about the other two
bozos that you got to
tell about the other process the first
one
uh we got together okay were you guys
already engaged are we just in a
relationship no it's two weeks after we
where was this in [ __ ] vegas jersey
down the shore even worse no down the
shore weehawken
um all right so how long jesus this is
insane how long have you been together
year and a half so if you do get married
and say last year
well we will oh you just say you get
married and you last 20 years or you're
gonna like
every year get five new you'll have like
[ __ ] ten thousand jake tattoos by the
end of your marriage yeah i'm down
is that a continuing thing or do you
feel like you've had enough jake
um i think we've moved on to maybe
matching matching tattoos
okay how many tattoos garbage coupling i
like that
i don't i don't know 100 yeah 60s let me
ask this as
someone who's experienced with tattoos
when you go in to get matching tattoos
do you get a deal
no no deal there's no discount that's it
foley's out
yeah do you put like you probably take a
military id
or a girl like you have an artist i have
my cover-up guy
and you know what it's been when you got
a cover on here yeah yeah
[ __ ] went south with tony
break out lucille can you turn that y to
an m i just i'll find a guy named tom
oh my god wow so that's where the
garbage rolls in i suppose yeah there we
go
what did you what do you what did you do
in the summer as a kid
where would you guys go on vacation
where did this come from rockaway or
does your dad have tattoos was your dad
a motorcycle guy
what is this whole thing and do you have
a motorcycle i do yeah you have you
personally have a motorcycle you ride
first yeah
i don't know i have an 85 iron head
sounds cool
that is cool i got a 76 fat head right
here
[Laughter]
bonus points is that the year you were
born
[Laughter]
i was some quick math in my head
funny and accurate huh no fake news here
that's an 11
40 out there guys that's that's what 11
40 gets you
holy did you grow up riding motorcycles
no you didn't
no so you was anybody in the family into
motorcycles no no no no so who got you
into motorcycles danny
jake oh jacob oh new jake all right
okay what she's still young though man
thing still figuring it out i know
mm-hmm
you know it's okay but what's the
dan does it say daniel or does it say
danny it said daniel now it's a
butterfly
i like it so i can't hate it yeah huh
cocoon butterfly growing up
if any of these guys ever sold weed is
what i want to know no no
well i don't know not when they're with
me
okay anybody any biker were the other
two guys biker guys too
no no they were just regular dudes were
they tattoo guys
one was tattoo guy one was just out of
character for me
and
okay not my type but you still got his
name tattooed yeah cause i'm [ __ ]
crazy
did he have any picking up on that
[Laughter]
coming in what you're putting down there
natalia
did he have any tattoos at the time the
first guy or the app the the one that
was out of character
out of character never doesn't have any
tattoos so you just went like hey i got
a tattoo of you yeah we were long
distance in one day
oh
that's stalking what are you talking
about
do you have how long distance um
california new york it's pretty long
it's pretty long so
yeah i'm stable i love it that's okay
it's okay stable doesn't really
unstable the only thing i don't know the
tattoos are that's tough to bounce back
from
really i mean you have yeah you have
multiple men's names
no they're covered they're gone but they
were were they bad breakups too
um one of them was a bad breakup yeah
bad breakup's always a good sign
any cops ever involved no no no there's
check-ins
i don't know i don't know you never know
um you know i will redeem myself by the
end of the session okay
okay i'm still on i mean you got some
you know we gotta stay we'll stay away
from the family stuff we'll give you an
opportunity to redeem yourself
we'll focus on natalie now ah thank you
with the 12 tattoos
12 16. is there anything in your house
that says live laugh love
no no you're us your very anti that i
would pick up yeah i'm not it's not my
vibe yeah okay
um where are you you guys live together
now you and your fiance yes
apartment home apartment apartment okay
all right fair enough do you guys have
any home improvement projects that have
been left
undone that have been sitting around for
a half-painted bathroom half-painted
bathroom
a shelf that's in the hallway shout out
to my wife okay okay
um if i went over to your house right
now what would
and i asked for water what would you
give me a cup out of the sink
brita bottle whatever i got sent
like four cases of these cans of water
i'd probably give you one of those
promo you're giving us promo cans yeah i
don't hate it yeah i give you a promo
okay gotta use it if you guys is it in
the fridge
yeah it's in the fridge and you still
have some that's not in the fridge like
you still have a stocked up
i have some outside in the backyard you
got a yard yeah [ __ ]
i got a yard however she's got yard
money yeah
where okay so i gotta get a motorcycle
so you got cases of water that are out
back on the porch
yeah okay that's fair no that's garbage
because my aunts and my
uncle used to keep cases of soda out on
the on on the back porch
i got sparkling on the porch still in
the fridge that's pretty i mean
it's not great it's not bottled still
canned
oh still what's up what's the brand
liquid death
knew it yeah yeah what the [ __ ]
it's called murder juice yeah i thought
you're gonna say you got a couple cases
of lacroix or something
around now she's got a little harder a
little more edge to her
than lacroix certain depth
what's it called liquid death yeah
it's delicious that's great all right do
you have your passport
yeah when did you get it uh when i was a
kid
where did you go um my parents were
together we would go to
cool places in europe that's great
okay then when they separated we started
going to baltimore
they had good crack what do you want
talking about the bottom did you go to
the aquarium yes oh that's right
that's trash i love the aquarium it's
fun it's fun for a kid but i mean if
you're going to baltimore if you're
going to the baltimore aquarium and you
live in new york
new jersey pennsylvania it's a trash
vacation baltimore's a tough get i don't
know
first of all you drive by four different
aquariums to get to baltimore aquarium
there's one there's one in philly
there's a couple in jersey baltimore
aquarium
rocks it is pretty good i stand by this
baltimore as a whole that was
pretty crack man and it really is it's
like what are you doing here that's
every time i think of baltimore what's
going on here what are we doing here why
don't you live in dc or philly or
whatever
um european trips as a kid such as
where'd you go dude we went to [ __ ]
italy portugal
spain so there was a little cash rolling
around here yeah i mean
it's not like a lot it's not crazy we
never went to [ __ ] europe as a kid
yeah because you're uncultured idiots
we went down the shore and that's an
expensive [ __ ] vacation yeah
i'd say it's a similar similar price
once you get you know
pay for the plane i mean that was
probably that was costing your parents
thousands of dollars
yeah to go take a whole family down the
shore for a week how come we didn't go
to europe
because you had too many siblings i bet
just two yeah it's too many
no it's also oh two yeah you weren't
only child two so it's kind of just like
your parents went on vacation a little
bit as well they don't have to take the
whole family
that makes sense so i'm different that's
classy
it's very hey man people get divorced
people fall out of love
are you gonna do what you got to do they
lived together for a little while they
[ __ ] tried maybe maybe they were
trying to make it work for all we
[ __ ] know
and then senior year in high school they
were like you know what [ __ ] it i'm
moving to queens with the kid
um have you ever been to a ruby tuesdays
no pretty good olive garden no outback
steakhouse yes
okay recently not recently
not recently ever worked at any of these
places
what were some of the jobs you had high
school college et cetera et cetera um i
worked at
max bratwurst in astoria i worked at
this
place upstate for a few years in college
called hotel tivoli then i moved down i
worked at gossip coffee and variety
coffee
so all pretty pretty good and changed
pretty cool yeah the bratwurst place is
that like a local staple
no it's trash but it's not because it's
it's
it's own you know it's independent yeah
okay it's not a chain
yeah all right pretty cool gossip coffee
that's pretty fancy right
i don't know what sounds it yeah yeah
gossip girl cool is that playing
does anyone in your family play scratch
off lottery tickets no
sorry i shouldn't laugh no no okay
if you play scratch off a lot look at
down the barrel if you play scratch off
lottery tickets you're trash
yeah okay yeah there's no qualms here
you're garbage that's on the short list
for my christmas list i want the new one
that they have
yeah the diamond game it's 30 bucks you
got to
you have to 30 you got to win something
every time
for 30 bucks you gotta win
dude i want five for sure i for sure get
scratchers every christmas yeah
yeah and i say i let the kids scratch
them off but i know what's
[ __ ] i got my lucky quarter and
everything lucky quarters
oh yeah is it your birth year no just a
quarter that i should say
whatever yeah that's my last one
[Laughter]
do you eat cottage cheese no
middle name i have two middle names here
we go there's one
are you catholic no one is hannah which
is normal
the other one's my mom's last name which
is sporn sporn
why do you have two middle names did
they say my mom my mom
wanted her name to be included
i never understood i never knew why she
was on the couch
a little pushy throwing the name on
there
do you know how old you were the first
time you had lobster
she's traveling to italy she probably
had all that [ __ ] no i mean i was a
vegetarian for
probably like two years ago i had
lobster i think you were classy and now
you became
trashy oh she's still pretty i mean
there's not
much super trashy i mean the tattoos is
tough
the mom on the couch for a decade tough
let's talk about the apartment
okay any beaded curtains separating the
rooms no
look how cool she is
not shopping at spencer's dude
feeded curtains does anyone say yes to
that i have a couple of guys i wanted to
put one in my wife was like are you
sure what i'm saying just i'm going on
the whole the whole motorcycle vibe
any wait you think beaded curtains are
motorcycle vibe i don't know
i have limited access to that world dude
if you got them you're going on a couple
old episodes of chips that i saw
what do you want from me you'd be the
guy on the trike you'd have the two
wheels yeah you couldn't yeah you
couldn't bounce no no no no no
never one of those big bikes when you
see the old couples driving
like the couples that are retired they
have like the huge saddle things on the
side they have like headsets and stuff
like that
yeah radio going yeah or i'd be in the
little cart the little
side car yeah i'd be i'd be rocking it i
had one of those on my bike as a kid it
was
what that's sweet put your dog in it no
i didn't have a dog at the time put my
friend mad in it
how did you put that that must have been
a lot of pendleton
that's like rickshaw work that's that's
[ __ ] up no because
the guy would push it the sidecar guy
would push it till you get going it's
[ __ ] sweet dude
jump in it like a boss my stepdad made
it for me because he's like wow
he like he's a crazy mechanic guys so he
built it like then all the tubes and
stuff and [ __ ] welded it on it was
[ __ ]
dude i was [ __ ] making side cars
[Laughter]
he's got a shop okay it's not we're
[ __ ]
tack welding in the basement do you have
any candles
large candles that you just let melt
into the table
no that they all have candle holders
yeah yeah
any skull candle holders skull
skull like a human skull not real skull
but like do you have any skulls in your
house i do have some skulls
is that trashy it ain't classy i'll tell
you that lady
what are you talking about skull there's
no skulls at my mom's house
unless it's [ __ ] a couple days before
the 31st and there's a couple of [ __ ]
sweet talks
oh man what are the skulls there's like
one
gold skull piggy bank i'll give you that
it's functional at least yeah
i i know what you're saying i bet your
apartment's probably cool as [ __ ] it is
cool
yeah but and then there's like some i
don't know deer skull thing
yeah i feel like that's rustic
no that's trash it's garbage yeah they
got one at the white house
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what is that dear knots antelope yeah
rub it for good luck
go get the scratchers and rub the deer
head whoa i would i would
i i mean you're it's also tough because
you're very cool you are a very cool
person she's a dress is very cool so it
is cool
i think most people that would have a
deer if it was me
yeah it would yeah
it's a little different and it's more
stylish it's more yeah
it's a little different but it ain't it
ain't classic and you're vegan now you i
heard you no no no during the pandemic i
started eating meat again
okay i think she got the deer head yeah
don't
is your boyfriend vegetarian or vegan no
no no okay
but for how long were you a vegan uh
eight years vegetarian
vegetarian for eight years now you're
off i'm off okay
hmm do you have any cats no dog
dog yes okay what kind of dog probably
cool dog he's
awesome he's does he have a motorcycle
he's no
he wants one chopper he's a he's like a
mutt
he's like a aussie cattle mint pin kind
of rescue
yeah pretty cool yeah all right rescue
dogs i love him pretty classy
interesting go-to salad dressing what go
to salad dressing um
vinegar like some sort of vinaigrette i
was looking for a hidden valley ranch
[Laughter]
let's see if you got any on you was the
correct answer
pretty classy what about in the shower
do you have a lot of empty shampoo
bottles everywhere
no no i think you're just describing
your house at this point
you keep empty shampoo bottle because
you want the last little there might be
some in there i don't know
i'm not a trial here yeah yeah yeah
you're on it
what about the soap is it bar is it uh
or is it it's very nice
it is like myers yeah she's not using
irish spring
okay no we're good not a bar dial
anything like that
oh sorry no no no i just i get excited
about soap and stuff me too i'm a big
soap guy yeah
beekman 1802 goats milk soap that's what
we're rocking oh wow
[Music]
it doesn't wash off you though i feel
like i'm in [ __ ] earners i feel like
i'm in the weather churning me or
something
it keeps it hard yeah it's louder it
keeps a coat on you
like some sealant it's like waterproof
you start beating up
it's good [ __ ] though ever wait in line
to meet a celebrity
no ever been a member of a studio
audience no
bam do you drink yeah what's your go-to
drink
um i like cider hard cider apple cider
i like apple cider yeah i mean no horse
hard cider
i like apple cider with with spiced rum
apple cider with spices my festive drink
yeah it's pretty festive yeah it's gonna
make hold out you get that going curl up
so fun
you make it at the house you heat up the
cider yeah yeah it's nice
you have a fireplace damn i was just
going to say that
in the apartment it's electric yeah oh
no it's nice nice wait electric house
like there are coals that you like
uh turn on yeah that's nice wait a
minute
there's no actual flame there's a flame
there's a flame but you turn it on
what's the power what's keeping the
flame going is it get hooked up to a gas
it's electric yeah it's electric boogie
woogie woogie what are you not getting
about it's electric wait a minute hold
on
but there's gas that feeds into it no
it's electric probably
how can there be flames if it's electric
i don't know they're called electric
i don't know how it works but there's an
on button
i don't know what you're trying to pull
sounds like a black and decker um
okay okay you have a fire pit outside in
the backyard i do
do you have exposed brick in your house
no okay
any artwork hanging on the walls artwork
yeah anybody we know
this is the same thing that happened
with ralph remember ralph sutton yeah
what happened with him he's a big you
know you're you're you're just classy
you're rocking roll
yeah he's rocking yeah yeah yeah yeah we
thought it would be [ __ ] easy
i mean we got you a little bit we got
you a little i mean the tattoos are
tough i shouldn't have given it away
honestly that's
what he meant so we won i know you don't
got to play defense in here
vote magazine over here come on you're a
good company
have you ever made nachos in the
microwave yeah that's pretty trashy
not often but it doesn't matter it's
trashy right
huh brush your teeth in the shower no
why do you say it like that i do
sometimes but not really
okay yeah okay yeah yeah get the butter
on the counter keep it in the fridge
fridge interesting what do you where do
you shop at where's your grocery store
skull and bones i
death is pure you gotta have the
avocados though they're unbelievable i
do like the hoboken target
it's a little trashy it's all right
target i mean you know
they know they know what they're doing
one stop shop
stop the two of you stop they have
organic [ __ ]
i know fully targets garbage i'm not
saying it's classy
i'm not getting my milk the same place i
can get a [ __ ] button-down shirt
triple xl
really because it's the same brand
that's gonna be at stop and shop yeah
it's changed i understand what you're
thinking you're thinking from 15 years
ago
it's different i didn't know about
target 15 years ago okay
i like trader joe's i just i like that
uh we're big trader joe yeah i like
trader joe's
went this sunday you know what trader
joe's is good at they do everything for
you they have like these little snacks
and you know what they have that i can't
shake a stick at they got [ __ ] little
pretzel bites that have peanut butter
and
oh my god yeah yeah yeah and [ __ ]
crush those
nothing wrong with a [ __ ] bag of
pretzel bites a little peanut butter in
it
fantastic you're pre-diabetic there is
something wrong with that i can't have
any more
if i do i just have a handful and i'm
having them and i'm your hands are huge
that's way more than a serving size big
fella i'm pre-pre-diabetic
do you know how to operate a forklift by
any chance no okay
do you know how to fix anything on the
motorcycles
yeah that's part of that's their gear
that's pretty classy though
it is classy but it's kind of gross too
what does your boyfriend do what does
your fiance do so he uh he works at this
uh
place that they make magnetos which is a
thing that you put on a motorcycle so
you can run it without a battery
and it makes it go faster sounds like
it's in the future this year
magnetos i thought you were going to try
to play defense about the place
he works at this place thing they're
they make burgers they're kind of the
king it's you know
i thought it was going to be something
but that's i got to find skilled labor
skilled labor that's pretty impressive i
got a buddy who's once you get into
motorcycles you're like in there in the
world it's like he's same thing
he started you know rev something
everything every hey you got a new job
it's always like yeah i'm at muffler inc
or something
oh they can they play it close to the
chest those motorcycle guys
did you ever have family that lived with
you no
pretty good i have a quick one toby
please so you got the magazine
class of trash classy trash classy
trashy magazine great everyone go check
it out
yeah what do you define as trashy what
do i define as trashy yeah it's pretty
good
um
[Music]
i mean that's a uh just it's very ellen
question
i guess just like
stuff that's busted i don't know just
like yeah not refined
strapping stuff together kind of i think
for the magazine it's more like
it's like real people which shouldn't be
trashy but it's like it's not supposed
to be as refined it's
not like it's not as elegant it's not as
polished very real yeah but the layout's
really cool
the layout's cool yeah yeah it looks
really sharp thank you
so we can't say it's garbage hmm
how do you pronounce the things you
color with like the wax things you color
with like a coloring book
how do you make them crayola makes them
how would you pronounce that crayon
crayon that's right what's the choice i
was like are we playing people say
crayon
crown i say crayon yeah it's crayon yeah
cause you're [ __ ] garbage but
crayon crayola crayons oh my god
i say crowns sometimes but it's crayons
like we say what crowns i'm garbage
everywhere pounds
crowns this guy's fun falling on the
steps
my dad always said hey go get the crowns
oh my god wow wow
yeah we're trash have you ever owned a
hacky sack no
skateboard yeah i mean
yeah she'll do a kickflip hmm
pull that couch at the house right now
no interesting have you ever worn a make
seven up yours t-shirt
because i have that's specific i got
kicked out of holland junior high for
that [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] i don't know she's getting
bulletproof here do you know how to use
the devil sticks
what the sticks with the two the two
sticks and you hit the stick back and
forth devil sticks no no no can you
juggle
the way she said she's the way she asked
me what i was sponsored i thought i was
i thought i didn't know what i was
talking about i'm like the things with
the things
she looked into my [ __ ] soul dude
i was like what are you talking about
baldi who were you
ew you're old gross
dude that she like looked and then
looked to get like
through me all right that's good you're
pulling out of it here yeah
okay have you ever smoked pot out of a
soda can yes
recently no okay there's any other drugs
out of a soda can
um i don't understand how no me either
moving right along um
is the bed in the corner of your room
apparently no
there is room on both [ __ ] sides baby
is there a box spring or i'm sorry is
there a bed frame or is the bed on the
floor
bed frame pretty good bad for him canopy
any mirrors or anything like that
mirrors
like you ever see somebody who has a cat
wait white top gun isn't that the thing
i thought it was in the sex scene
there's drapes and flowy
it's just drapes and cinematography i'm
talking like one of those we know what a
canopy is
they're pretty garbage okay i think
they're pretty classy okay
i don't know hmm
can you whistle with your fingers no can
you do anything weird with your toes
like pick things up
or draw or anything like that are you
currently double joining
no you ever see the kid that does that
one
that guy didn't work out to match he hit
the bricks that guy didn't become a
lawyer
when the [ __ ] kid at the bus stop
could [ __ ] put his arm up his ass
that was always [ __ ] freak show hmm
what were the pets growing up
or karen i mean apparently you have a
dog what were the pets i have a dog i
had two frogs and
hermit crabs oh frogs are no no boys
i'll come back
it's not like she said lion they're like
honey they're like a little fish tank i
don't know the mom's in the living room
where are you
what do you mean don't look at me like
i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i think i grew up trashy i do trashier
than you are now
garbage you're pretty rough i am putting
myself i mean you're yes
you have one together one no no
i don't have wine glasses in your house
currently i do the big ones
like the nice ones i have multiple sizes
very good when was the last time you had
a rotisserie chicken
um rotisserie taking like a full cooked
chicken
yeah like from get them at the grocery
store do you not know what we're talking
about no i do i just started eating meat
guys it's true i'm just saying if you're
going to know
i've had to know that yeah you would
have to i would have given the keys to
the studio literally
that's [ __ ] clay you don't know what
a roto is wow roto gang stand up
those shirts are coming soon where are
you at
um hmm did you ever have a cookie cake
for your birthday growing up
a cookie cake yeah she's why i don't
know how man she scares me when she
she responds imagine getting in she
turns she turns her head like a dog
who's like
i think you're an android or something
cookie cake
you're talking it was like your
artificial intelligence scaring the [ __ ]
out of it yeah like the cake it's like a
big cookie
okay i mean it's pretty good have you
ever sent an unprovoked dm
to a celebrity yes i have whoa
who was it i honestly were you sliding
one of them was it chris
angel or somebody like that because
there's
was it manson or somebody who else no no
i've uh
i've slid into jason momoa's dms i think
that makes sense i would do that
too i mean that's a fair game yeah i'll
give you that and just like as an
attempt to be like yo what's good
what are you doing you're in town i got
your name tattooed on my channel
give me a call
i got your name tattooed on my stomach
eight times if i don't hear back it's
gonna be nine times
i'm sincerely yours natalie
it's just a picture of his name on my
ass what
i'm kidding
no sports team tattoos or anything like
that right no she hasn't pegged me for a
football fan
no tasmanian double tattoos or anything
like that
all right pretty have you ever owned a
snuggie
no have you ever ordered a shamwell no
have you ever sold anything door to door
over the phone no
do you have what kind of uh your
silverware is it a sink is it a set or
is it all mix and match
it's a ikea set yeah yeah how many forks
would you say you have your currently
have
you know i've got the big forks and the
little guys wow you got salad forks
what'd you have for breakfast um
i didn't eat this morning intermittent
fasting very classy
do you have dinner plans for tonight
because there's something sitting out
no there's some chicken and broccoli at
home not chicken like there's chicken
and
there's broccoli there's chicken
uncooked chicken no there's cooked
chicken and some
baked broccoli and cauliflower in the
fridge is the chicken grilled or is it
breaded and fried it's uh it's
it was in the oven it was in the oven
those are the only two chickens for you
was it grilled or breaded and fried
the stinker was lost
did it have mommy sauce on it yeah
otherwise there's no healthier way to
cook chicken
what i'm trying to get to is well will
under normal circumstances not the
pandemic you know
you and your boyfriend both their
fiancee have busy lives will you take
something out of the freezer
and leave it in the sink to defrost oh
well that's not trashy
i think that's much garbage why my mom
have to defrost it like i don't leaving
[ __ ] in the sink while you're at work
all day
it's not i don't know how else do you do
i mean if you try to microwave it that's
trashy
yeah yeah they actually fall out you eat
bacon now i do eat bacon
and where do you cook the bacon you cook
it in the microwave or in a skillet on
the in the skillet yeah yeah
she's not do you have a grill at the
house in the backyard yeah charcoal or
gas
both what do you mean both i have both
girls so you got the old schooler
yeah and then you have a gas yeah yeah
yeah not bad
yep any burners on that gas grill on the
side
side burners you could like heat a pot
of baked beans or something
um and or do you know the name brand of
it
you got a weber yeah really oh that's
pretty crazy
it's actually a really [ __ ] nice girl
just got it
this girl's put together and i'm getting
my life in check you guys
okay you have a bean bag at your
apartment no okay
moving on
well thanks for stopping by uh how do
you feel about still cross pizza
what stuffed crust pizza dude
i've never been so shook by a guest in
my life
never had it i'm sorry a couple of dorks
over here
you put chicken out of the army with you
what's the tv situation over there big
screen actually
daniel got me a tv when i yeah yeah yeah
yeah and how does jake feel about that
he loves it he's watching the big screen
so what are you guys
[ __ ] some dude hey thanks a lot danny
boy i'll send you the time warner bill
when it comes
what are we talking about here big
screen nice yeah it was so big that i
said to my therapist the tv is too big
but i've never had that problem
have you ever had uh backstage passes
no i've never had backstage passes
that's a good question though that is
pretty good
you seem like a backstage pass kind of
gal i can see that yeah
backstage at like a rat concert or
something have you ever crowd surfed
no okay who's your favorite band
i like the grateful dad didn't see that
coming pretty good
i don't know how to feel about that one
i like them too
have you ever been on a cruise no damn
anybody in your family ever owned a
convertible no i've never been in a
convertible
really yeah that's weird yeah it is that
might be trashy
i know i don't know you've never been in
a convertible
got a pt cruiser or something like that
oh man i was saving that question for
somebody
anyone in your family owned a pt crew
what about when you were on vacation in
italy weren't you zipping around in a
something a [ __ ] fiat yeah give you a
lamborghini when you got there right now
is that what you think italy is ah about
your honor
let's give you a pizza we're missing out
on all that coffee give me a pizza and a
[ __ ] convertible
ah we got nothing i mean yeah she's
pretty bullied i mean she's got a couple
of tendencies
fish tanks in the apartment now no no no
what does that mean
no i used i used to have fish tanks when
i was a kid who didn't have a fish tank
yeah
pretty good have you ever owned a snake
or a lizard
no do you sleep with a fan directly on
you no
how many pillows do you how many pillows
are on the bed right now
uh we have a king-sized bed with seven
pillows
[Laughter]
he's more of a twin if you catch my
drift huh king-sized bed
with room on the side yeah in the middle
of the room it's jersey
jersey now when you sleep
do you have pillows how many what's the
sleeping positions
i like to be on the side like lie on my
side okay
i have either one really flat pillow or
sometimes use the second one
uh-huh jake does the pillow between the
legs
garbage need it we gotta have it right
dog in the bed
dog in the back that's i like that
that's all right be considered
it's not yeah i mean it's dirt you got a
city dog a city dog in the
in the bed yeah but i love him so much
he's the best
i also don't love germs though that's
gross really
yeah no when we go home to my parents if
we don't bring the cat if we're just
going for like a night or something like
that
the dog will sleep in the bed with us
it's the best yeah i'll go back
in the morning but it's training where
else are you supposed to put the dog
i don't know out back people don't
i mean what's your dog's name rory good
name he's pretty good
yeah that's a pretty good dog name yeah
does he have one of those spike collars
no no he is does he have any tattoos no
i have a tattoo of him
okay that's like dmx why
he's got a picture of his one love
boomer that's the first dog that he had
that died it broke his
broke his heart earl simmons never
bounced back from that one love boomer
he got a bit like the
world's worst tattoo on his back it
looks like i drew it it's horrible
do you have a grateful dead tattoo no
that would be trashy any other bands
though
no i don't have any bands do you have
any other sayings sayings or words like
loyalty and strength a lot of my friends
have those
i have queens most of them are in rehab
queens is all right i mean if you're
not queens i give it to you yeah one if
you're already in the tattoo world and
you know you're a queen's gal i guess
yeah yeah
hmm i had one but i forgot it oh any
incense burning at the apartment
i don't like incense no do you sage the
apartment i have staged it in the past
but i haven't recently have you ever had
your palm read no
ever been to a medium no oh pretty good
so this is
it's interesting because i feel like
those are expensive things what getting
your palm read
no going to a medium i guess it would
cost you get a
coupon yeah it could be some housewife
and [ __ ] jersey
have you ever left a bad yelp review
oh that's not a no i think i got her
here i think i said
i've obviously i have giraffe yes i have
off to back
tweet the deets i have but i have had a
bad yelp review written about me so i
feel like
you're on yelp where you have coffee
yeah the coffee shops they would talk
[ __ ] about
or talk [ __ ] on the whatever yelp about
you yeah
yeah yeah yeah well they would be like
let me get a medium coffee and you were
like what
i slammed the card on the table what do
you mean
apparently they caught like their credit
card they i swiped it and apparently i
slammed it on the table when i gave it
back to them
and you're supposed to hand it to them
oh you're a little crazy the fact you
haven't forgotten that and i could tell
it still bothered you
she's like apparently you're supposed to
hand it back to them
wait well that tattoo is coming it was
like
midtown what was your it was what got on
in midtown that was the
coffee shop that happened what was the
yelp review
that you left oh my god this place in
jersey city
called mod cup okay you're doing it
coffee
mon cup coffee yes exactly another
coffee shop
yes jesus did you start out i usually
don't do this but
um i did yeah it's my only daddy
pull it up you got it you got it pull it
up this is trashy i have a fake yelp
account
that i'm logged into right now and not
that one and i have a fake name
you got a burner yelp account
she's just people she's leaving she's
leaving reviews at her old cafe
i miss natalie so much she handed me my
credit card perfectly every time
so yeah holy [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah i'm
okay
i just want to review here mom's on the
couch mom's on the couch
for a decade 10 years
from 5-15
the tattoos tattoos of
she has multiple men's name tattooed
covered up the the aquaman the [ __ ]
stock letter that awkward lying in the
dms sliding into jason
bad yelp reviews one bad yelp review
she's got skulls at the house
[Laughter]
dog in the bed i'm not doing the dog in
the back
thank you i mean given all right we got
one two three four five like six or
seven bad answers maybe but we asked you
about [ __ ]
500 questions true we normally i mean
the tampon and the sci-fi thing oh [ __ ]
it
but that's more of an opportunity you
know what i mean that's that's you're
hemmed up in advance
i get i get that trashier that or having
like stained pants and unions
i understand have you ever pooped your
pants no you want to
[Laughter]
um i think that's it for i mean
this girl's pretty good pretty good
i don't think i got a good case to say
she's garbage all class
oh my god thank you god i wouldn't say
all class
mostly i mean you know
you're a woman you gotta do what you
have to do you're in a bad situation
what are you gonna do yeah
what are you gonna do hmm so i i can't
even even you [ __ ] your past your
parents they you know your mom might
have been sleeping on the couch but
you're still [ __ ]
hobnobbing off the [ __ ] you're up like
that that's pretty good
yeah baltimore though yeah baltimore
how many times did you go to baltimore
went to baltimore several times did you
stay there or drive home
we spent the night ooh why
how was that a vacation aquarium was
nice
but that's what you did hey we're gonna
go to baltimore again for
we go to baltimore mystic seaport what's
the mystic seaport
the sea oh on the yeah um philly
dc those were like the the post
separation
vacation spot we're from philadelphia
but they go to each other bad vacation
no so one of them would take who would
take you on these days my mom my mom
oh man so that's taken to europe
mom's going no they were going they went
to europe together then
yeah i mean italy and [ __ ] prague to
philly and baltimore
is a change that's a tough one
but you can't blame her on her past no
you're all class buddy
class in my book oh my god this is a
great day i'm gonna get your names
tattooed
perfect ending fatso and the other guy
fatso and the bald man holy [ __ ]
natalie what do you want people out
there to know we obviously have the
magazine
i have the magazine i have the podcast
uh thurstrat podcast
uh you can follow it on instagram at
thurstrap the pod follow me on instagram
at natalie cuomo underscore
and check out my magazine classy trashy
magazine and they can find clashy trashy
on instagram correct yes at classy trash
magazine
very nicely unbelievable great times
very fun kippy what do you got to tell
them out there guys as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes keep us in the top 200 or get us
back there whenever you're hearing this
also full video full hd video available
on youtube
subscribe there as well shirts are
available at podcastmerch.com
get those perfect for the holiday season
stocking stuffer go with a little couple
of scratchers
uh and then patreon.com guys go sign up
you can get bonus content you can help
us support help us keep the [ __ ]
lights
on here help us uh you know pay for the
big bands uh fried chicken or whatever
he does
and i'm at kevin ryan comedy on all
social media at age foley on ice on
twitter foleygrams on instagram
big shout out to our main man t-bone
mcmullen
producer extraordinaire at toby.mcmullen
on instagram
very nice and gang if you're hearing
this uh
relatively soon have a safe and happy
holiday weekend
and we'll see you guys next time peace